[Music]
jason
is with us in detroit hi jason welcome
to the dave ramsey show
hey dave thanks for taking my call how
are you better than i deserve how can i
help
well i had a question for you um i've
been working with a financial advisor
who's given me some advice
and i follow the show i'm on baby step 7
currently
but he presented me with an idea that
was a little outside the box
and i have term life insurance i've been
anti
whole life but he presented me with this
infinite banking concept
jesus you're kidding me yeah i have
excess money in a savings account
and looking to rebalance my portfolio to
get it to work a little bit harder but
my risk tolerance is a little bit low
and he showed me how you can do this
where you over fund the whole life
policy
you can access the money you break even
in year seven and then the dividend
outruns what you put into it yeah it
doesn't seem like a terrible idea
in that regard but i just wanted your
your take on why
you know that might not be the best way
to go
the the problem is that you where it
gets confusing
is that um god he's sona
dividend a financial advisor assistant
this is an insurance guy
well he's he's both they have you know
it's one of the bigger
companies um northwestern mutual or
prudential
exactly yeah okay he's an insurance guy
he's not a financial advisor
okay so because those are both mutual
companies now
there are two types of life insurance
companies mutual and stock
okay likely you bought your term unless
you bought it from him
from a stock company a stock company
stockholders owned the insurance company
a mutual company which is prue and
northwestern state farm is mutual is the
policy holders are actually the
stockholders
okay okay so when the
company makes a profit
the policyholders receive a dividend
as if they were a stockholder and
received a dividend
does that make sense yep now follow the
math here
if you are the owner of the company and
you're also the customer
of the company and the only place the
company gets money is from
the customers that are owners and they
give you money
from a profit by definition
that means it's because they took too
much from you
as a customer there wouldn't have been a
profit otherwise
okay so the irs has deemed consequently
that mutual life insurance company
dividends
are not dividends in the true sense of a
dividend
that instead they are and this is the
irs's language
they are instead a refund of a
deliberate
overcharge so they overcharge you in
order to give you some money later
to make you feel like you're making
money off of them
and it's absolute hogwash it's a
pass-through mathematically it's a
pastor it's
the way it has to be it's the legal
definition the freaking company and the
irs
says so so yeah
the thing i didn't love is you know you
when you take the money back
you basically are paying an interest
rate on it exactly
and whose money is this right
that you're borrowing you're borrowing
your own money and you're paying them
interest
yep this is infinite banking for them
yeah yeah the infinite banking concept
is is
old school whole life done poorly
you need a real financial advisor not an
insurance broker
that's trying to sell you a load of
manure
and so yeah the other thing is that your
cash values that are sitting there
all die with you so whatever cash you
put into this
is equals zero at your death because
they only pay the face value
prue does not have a policy northwestern
mutual does not have a policy that pays
more than the face value
except universal life b's which are not
in infinite banking products
and universal product b is where they
charge more than they usually charge
which basically buys the insurance so
they can still keep your money
is the way the math actually works on
this so you're dealing with one of the
most expensive
insurance products in the marketplace if
you're dealing with either one of those
two companies
i would stay completely away from both
of them
they're um everyone in the financial
field except people that work for them
we all think they're a joke
of us anyone who's academically trained
or has any kind of cfp or anything else
when they when someone says they work
for northwestern mutual we just kind of
laugh
and go yeah right you screw people every
day
so dude you need to get away from them
and you need to go get
a real financial advisor that can help
you do some real
investing that takes into consideration
your low risk tolerance
low risk tolerance does not need to lead
you to losing your money
100 of the cash invested at death
yeah that's a bad risk tolerance thing
so you need to move on dude you need to
move on but because the
and the whole thing of the dividends are
paying for it
is such a joke because the dividends are
the refund of a deliberate overcharge
so who's paying for it if you're getting
dividends from if you own home depot
stock and you got dividends from that
then home depot's making a profit but
they're making a profit off of their
customers yes and i'm the
owner of the investment i get that
dividend that's
different then if i am the customer and
i'm the stockholder
thereby the only way i made a profit was
off of me
myself so i pay you an extra hundred
bucks and then you give me 70 of it and
i'm supposed to feel great about that
right
yeah so that's what this amounts to and
so
you guys working with state farm when
you get your little dividend check
that's what it is it's the refund of a
deliberate
overcharge irs verbatim says that
yeah and that's why you don't get taxed
on it if you get a dividend on home
depot stock
you get taxed on it as income because
it's real income
you really made an investment and then
you really made an income
so that's what's going on with that
stuff and so do not buy
anything in the life insurance world
based on dividends
uh you look at the price look at the
structure of the policy
and uh you'll usually find that mutual
companies by the way are the higher
priced
so when you go to a quote service
like a zander insurance and you get
quoted on term life insurance
you're going to find no mutual companies
in the 42
different companies that they give you a
quote from because they're not
competitive why because they charge more
so they can give some of it to you back
later
and make you feel like that you got
something that's really what it amounts
to and that's why you won't find them
they're not competitive yeah dave
you're fired up about this one man i'll
tell you what pisses me off
infinite banking my butt okay
infinite banking is for them yes the
only listen the only thing you
that that agent has for his whole life
is a need for your commission to be paid
to him
absolutely that's the only whole life
thing that is involved here
this these products are horrendous yeah
and
you know it's bad enough when they feed
on
the middle class but that guy's a baby
step seven man he's probably a
millionaire
yeah and and and they create such a
jumbled word picture that you can't cut
through the bs
and yet you know the thing about him
here's you notice what happened with him
this is interesting you know it didn't
feel right
yeah he felt it didn't he yeah he felt
it and that's probably because he's
going through our process and he knows
what we teach
well it's not just that he didn't just
say well dave says it's wrong right he's
there's something wrong here i just
can't put my finger on it yeah overpay
and get money back
but i mean you ever have those feelings
i don't know exactly what's wrong but i
smell a rat
yeah which means there's a dead rat in
the corner somewhere i just hadn't found
him yet or below the couch something
stinks in here
yeah something stinks in here something
got in the house and died
you know i got a smell in here what is
it something's wrong you got you can't
find it yeah you can't put your finger
on but how many times have you been in a
situation with a person
or with a product a financial product
you know you had one
you had one you were buying an item i
won't say what it was on the air
but you got the smell off the people and
you ran it what
three weeks ago what was it dave tell me
are you gonna have
it i'm not going to because because
they're they might be listeners and i'm
not gonna do that to you i'm gonna throw
you under the bus
you walked out of a deal into a
different deal
not long ago oh yes sir was it not the
same thing it was the exact
holy spirit inside of you said i smell
a something's not right
something be wrong with these people i
ran this deal
is there i can't put my finger on it but
this deal is bad yes
and you ended up in another deal there's
a much better deal because you listened
even though you couldn't logically
explain it you could listen to your
heart absolutely
listen to the bell when the bell rings
it's called the holy spirit yeah
this is the dave ramsey show